Fireworks!
Oh my god!
Right
in front of me!
What are you talking about?
They are right there!
We are looking at the fireworks together.
Look!
Wait,
hold on.
I forgot to change the settings.
There we go.
Anyways, guys!
Hello!
Today, you are getting all my back.
You got my back, right guys?
You've got my back!
Today is my back.
Meet those back!
Can I snap the straps like a middle school... No!
Minky3D, hi!
I felt like, I don't know, I wanna look at the fireworks.
But I wanted to look at them properly, so I had to be facing the fireworks.
There's gonna be a lot of stuff.
So...
I don't know, it's just for fun.
Don't feel like I'm gonna do this a lot or anything.
Until maybe I get my real 3D.
But for now, you know.
There's gonna be a little bit of stuff.
A little teensy, teensy bit.
You can't really see my hands, because my sleeves are so big.
You can kinda... Look at that!
Look, I'm typing!
I'm hacking.
Petal, petal, meet those back.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't make me come over there.
Your neck, your back, and then a couple of other things.
You're gonna break... Step on a crack, break Minto's back.
Don't do that, don't do that.
So yeah, today we'll be playing Fireworks Mania with Doki, with Snuffy, with Limu!
They're all set up, they're all waiting for me.
I said I wanted to talk to you guys first.
Sorry, my arms are gonna be quite scuffed, but they kinda work a little bit.
Do you like my hat?
Fireworks!
And it's gonna be totally normal, it's gonna be totally chill fireworks time.
Don't worry about it.
Tickly fingers.
The game title makes me think it was a spiritual successor to an old PopCap game.
What's that?
PopCap, which one is that?
Quick while she's looking away, MitoQ.
No, I can see, I can see, I can see!
Would you show the wisp your middle finger?
That's it.
That's my middle finger.
This is my index finger.
This is my middle finger.
I don't know why...
It's so small, it's like a worm.
How high can you raise your arms by the way?
Not...
Don't look!
Oh my gosh, higher than I thought.
Wait.
What if I... Wait, hold on.
Wait, my arm, my... Hold on.
Okay, okay.
Wait, but my arm is...
My arm is... My arm is blocking it.
So we'll just have it like this.
Fireworks with a Mito blush.
With Mito and with three other people and all of you guys.
So let's... I'm gonna jump into the call and we're just gonna have fun with it.
I've never played this game before, but it recently got multiplayer.
And it seems a little chaotic, so yeah.
She hates us so much she won't even look back at a shot.
Okay.
Okie dokie!
I'm coming in!
Nice timing.
What happened?
Hey gang, hey!
Hi!
My audio is all out of whack.
You have to... Wait, like on stream or like on the in-game?
On stream.
Okay, yeah, I was gonna say the audio for the game is like, you have to change the input.
Oh wait, is it in-game audio?
Oh yeah, there is in-game audio.
Okay, we'll do that then.
Probably, right?
Yeah.
Oh that's great, I can eat and you guys won't hear me.
Oh shit.
My chat will hear me, they'll judge me.
I just spilled my tea!
Did you get the link?
Did you click the link?
Let me... clicky clicky link.
I see it now.
Join session.
Snuffy, do you still talk to AI Laimu?
No dude, she was nothing in comparison to the real thing.
Comment AIL.
Pathetic.
Twisted feet.
We're in!
I see them, I see them in their chats.
Alright, now Snuffy's chat can expose Laimu.
Expose Snuffy to Laimu.
She does talk to AI.
Hell yeah.
Laimu chat knows how freaky I am.
They'll worry.
Chat, behave!
Be nice!
Get along with other chat.
Wait, you guys can combine chats?
They're always super nice.
Yeah, they're kissing right now.
Yeah, on Twitch you can combine, if you're collabing, you can combine your streams together.
So the numbers are also combined as well as the chat.
It's like a proper co-op.
We're gaming the system.
Yes, we're gaming the system.
They're gonna be the number one streamers for Fireworks Media.
It's a very competitive field, I'll have you know.
We need this boost, okay?
There's gonna be two people streaming Fireworks Media.
There's someone streaming Fireworks Media!
It's us, it's us!
We have to dominate Fireworks Media.
Sorry, Batman.
We're like the Joker coming in.
I hope this will get people interested in the game and they'll browse by category and realize there's only one person.
All interested in the game category will go straight towards Batman.
Not only is he Batman, he's German Batman.
Nice.
Okay, just ignore that, that's fine.
I don't know what that means in German, I'm not German.
I'm gonna pretend I know what you said.
I won't tell you then.
Mint, you don't even have a placeholder Twitch, do you?
Do you have a placeholder Twitch I can put in my title?
Oh, I do.
People think it's fake.
I don't remember it, hold on.
It could be fake.
It's made mint underscore channel.
Oh wait, CH, not channel.
CH.
Made mint underscore CH.
Oh, the power move with no display picture or anything fantastic.
Oh my god, how did these 492 people found your channel?
I've used it to chat before, but I usually get timed out in people's chat.
They're just like, that's not real.
Well, look at this faker pretending to be mint that's fucked up.
Let me just VIP you so if you ever do show up, my mods don't kill you.
There's like a lot of German servers in the map for this game.
The Germans really love this game.
I see like literally 1, 2, 3, 4 German servers.
Oh my god.
By the way, there's not a lot of servers, but there's like 1 third of this is German.
What in the multiplayer?
Yeah, in the multiplayer, you look in there and you see...
Oh, German.
There's like a German town.
There's like...
There's Thomas, Tom, Emil, there's Dad, there's... I'm pretty sure it was MaxterGal, that has to be German, right?
I love German, like with the exclamation points.
No wonder German Batman was there.
Oh my gosh, someone in my chat just said Batman stream gained 30 viewers.
Hell yeah.
We're doing it.
It's like all 30 German people watching us are like, oh, okay, I'm gonna go watch in my native language.
Yeah, I can't understand what they're saying.
At least I can relate to him.
I do like the one that's like, yo, I have hundreds of mods and you can set off like 10 million fireworks, you're freaking wild.
That's my favorite.
Oh, if only...
Is that something in Batman stream?
Yeah, Batman stream... No, Batman just gained lots of viewers because we mentioned him.
Shout out to Batman.
Shout out to German Batman.
I hope he's saving Germany right now.
People are gifting your channel subs to us.
Yeah, thanks for getting a sub to Mint.
Oh, thank you!
I didn't realize that this game feels like there's a lot of people talking about mods.
I'm assuming people mod the shit out of this game.
I guess so.
I mean, literally, it's like...
Firework mods.
This server... I know you're the first servers in your life.
This server is 125 mods and a limit of... what the f... a hundred... a million fireworks?
So join and play?
If only there was four spots we could join them.
I'm gonna leave you guys for this server.
Wait, I'm refreshing.
It's full.
Too bad for you.
I'm
the only one that's not streaming, so I'm gonna say, hey guys, look at this cool ass...
Wait, another German server just popped up.
It is a server with cool mods, apparently.
Are the mods, like, local then?
Because that seems kind of dangerous.
Like, you join a server and it's just like a load of swinging dicks or something.
I swear to God, if our fans suddenly bought fireworks because I mentioned this server...
I swear to God, guys.
How dare you take my cool server.
They could.
It's on sale.
Steam sale right now.
I think that'd be so cool.
People could mod, like, our emotes as fireworks.
What is the resolution on this game?
What is the resolution?
Wait, are you guys serious?
I'm not on a server.
I'm just sitting on the menu waiting and watching the German servers.
What the heck is this default resolution?
It's like...
What is it?
I'm not asking.
4000x500.
It's horizontal.
It starts so...
Mine is fine.
No, I'm looking...
Yeah, mine's fine.
This is the regular version.
Like, this is it by default.
I screenshotted it.
This is what it looks like.
I can't...
I don't...
Let me see.
Let me see how to...
Do you have, like, an extra long monitor?
No.
It's very horizontal.
Why does it look like that?
It wasn't like that at all.
What was that?
Now it went back when I tabbed into it.
I'll show you guys.
YouTube.
Hello, YouTube.
We're streaming on the YouTube.
Hold on.
I'm gonna become a part of your stream now.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm part of stuff.
We're streaming streams.
Fireworks radio.
That's me over there.
Looking good.
Oh, you know what?
I do want to open your stream.
I want to see how your 3D looks.
How's your 3D?
I'm touching your face right now.
I'm gonna go look at it.
Let's all go watch it.
I can sense the phantom touch.
It's extra strong.
No fear.
Cause she's a phantom.
She's a phantom.
You're caressing her.
I see.
Oh, wait.
Oh, Snuffy.
To be blessed with amazement.
Hey, what's going on?
Picking your nose, Snuffy.
Digging for gold.
Yeah, up in there.
Don't pick her nose.
I see what you're doing.
You're flying.
I got your nose.
Doki, do you want to make this server since you're not streaming?
Wait, why am I making?
Cause you're not streaming.
Ok, ok.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
Clap, clap.
Snap, snap.
Come on.
Your computer has all the resources to spare for this incredibly intensive firework server.
Yeah, and give us a million mods.
Alright.
I don't even think I can do mods.
I have to download it from the fucking work.
How do you do it?
Oh, is that how you do it?
I'm really looking at it.
They don't have Germantown.
I think that's a mod.
I was gonna do Germantown.
I was looking at, wait, there was one, the ski resort.
What's that one?
That one might be Christmas-y.
Wait, do they have a workshop or is it like externally hosted mods?
Cause I don't see a workshop page.
Oh, you don't?
I don't either actually.
No.
Mod.io.
Ok.
Alright, I'm making sure it's four players.
Oh, I can make it a join code.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Max allow spawn props per player.
Let's make it 50.
Wait, it says, oh, it says workshop on the left on the main screen.
Yeah, I know, but I don't want to download.
Oh, yeah, ok, mod.io.
Ok.
Literally, Limu said that.
50.
Ok.
I was on like the main page.
I didn't see it.
Alright.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Read terms of use.
I don't actually want to read.
Oh, Jesus.
Alright, let's see.
How do I invite?
Where the fuck is the code?
Where?
Literally, most of the mods are just like adding so many types of fireworks.
Alright, here we go.
You sent it?
Yeah, I did.
Ok.
I cannot get out of the fucking mod page.
Ok, there we go.
Multiplayer.
Got join code.
Wait, is it gonna show?
Does it show it?
It does, so don't capture until you do.
Ok, ok.
Oh God, I'm in the sky.
Am I a firework?
No, I'm no longer a firework.
There we go.
Good boy.
No mods will be loaded.
Ok, join.
Wait, accept terms of use.
Why do I have to accept the terms of use?
We don't even have mods, do we?
No.
No, I can't do a mods right now.
I have to accept the terms of use for the workshop, even if we don't have them.
That's funny.
I'm here.
Ok, I'm coming in.
Wait.
Oh, I'm in the sky, dude.
Oh my God, my sensitivity is so high in this game.
The footsteps are so loud.
Oh.
Wait, I set one off on the floor.
How do you guys set it off?
Am I just spawning it in?
This looks like a legal activity.
No, I'm pretty sure fireworks are illegal in America, isn't it?
No.
What the heck?
We have 4th of July.
What are you talking about?
But, like, not on 4th of July.
Depends on the area.
I don't know if you know this, but you are muted.
Yeah.
Wait, wait, wait, guys.
I'll be right back real quick.
I gotta make a work call.
Hello.
I don't know since...
What?
Since this is touching you.
I realized you were super quiet.
Guys, I'll be back in like 5 minutes.
I have a super important work call I forgot about.
Okay.
Wait, can the rest of us spawn fireworks or are we now just cursed to wander this town without fireworks?
There has to be more.
There's gotta be more somewhere.
I have so many good one-liners.
Wait, what?
Wait, wait, did you just think we were ignoring your wit or something?
You just thought we hated you or something?
No, I would never think that.
I'm usually quiet, so I just... I don't think anything.
That's okay.
I'll get it next time.
Wait, I can speed the time.
How do I do that?
Speed time.
Flashlight on.
Oh.
Speed time.
I was just gonna say that it was funny.
We're a bunch of dudes in hoodies, like, lighting off fireworks with lighters in the corner.
I know.
It looks so illegal.
We're causing a disturbance in a civilian neighborhood.
How'd you get that?
We're a bunch of ruffians.
Amazing granny.
Hit tab for the...
I found America-themed fireworks.
Wait, how do I let go of the fireworks?
I'm gonna explode.
Oh god, how do I let go of the fire...
How do I let go of the fireworks?
Ooh, ah...
Oh!
Did you just kill me?
I think I just killed Toki.
What?
How do I light this box?
Oh, Jesus!
Oh, my gosh!
Oh, where'd you guys go?
It's a slammer!
Wait, I'm lighting the slammer.
How do I light the messenger?
It's not lighting.
I think it's lighting!
I don't think we're very good at firework safety.
Oh my god, you can't light it and hold yourself in it.
You'll fly away.
Fly away now.
You'll just fly.
Fly away.
How do I just grab this?
How do you get the more fireworks?
What did you do?
What?
Hit tab.
Hit tab and then you can light the box.
Oh, thick billy.
Thick billy!
There he goes.
He made fireworks, I just wanna talk.
More billies.
Oh, I spawned too many.
I'm across town now.
I'll start walking back.
Oh my god!
I'm gonna explode Doki.
Okay, hold on.
There's a gas station.
I'm gonna light a fire.
How do I get it?
Someone's computer is gonna crash.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my goodness.
Alright, here we go.
Come on Doki.
Wait, did you guys... I don't see you anymore.
How do I plant this shit in the floor?
I don't know, I was trying to figure that too.
Maybe...
Wait, connect fireworks with different types of fuses.
Hold the fucking phone.
What?
Let's go Minecraft redstone.
Wait, I'm connecting all the thick billies.
Give me a minute.
Throw, rotate, hold.
The gas station is immune.
Actually no, I did blow it up though.
Alright, here we go Doki.
We're going together.
I made a ring of thick billies.
Here we go Doki.
Wait, can I make her shoot off the map?
This is my homework now.
This is what I want to do.
Oh my god!
Ok, you should definitely link them together.
It's really funny.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Wait, how do you link?
How do you link things?
So, the third one and then you like...
You find where the connection point is and you click them together.
Ok, let's see.
Wait, you what?
What?
So hit three and you'll see it has like a little stick.
And then you see on each firework there's like a little connection point.
Click between them.
And now they're linked.
Right click to stop.
I found a tube.
I don't know what the tube is for.
Oh my god!
Alright then.
Oh my god, is this fireworks?
I don't know.
I think these are for holding them up.
Oh, maybe.
Because the ones that are just shooting across are like...
The ones that are supposed to be in the ground are just shooting away.
Yeah, I don't know how to do it though.
Ok, drop.
What are you guys doing?
We figured out how to link fireworks together, which is very nice.
You gotta put the fireworks in first, Oxcapper.
I got a cake.
What the heck?
Oh, happy birthday!
A cake?
It's 2022, let's go!
Happy 2022, happy new year!
Here we go!
Do you like this?
Wait, I think I'll get candles.
Minecraft!
This is so cool!
Oh, I thought they were just blocks.
Minecraft.
I'm making a thing.
Why is a gingerbread man here?
That's me, bro.
That's me, yo!
Merry freaking Christmas!
Am I blue Santa?
Yeah, you're blue Santa!
I'm blue Santa!
Oh my god, Santa!
Wait, let's blow it up.
Santa.
Wait, can you blow up Santa?
Where are you, Santa?
I looked away for two seconds to link my fireworks.
Why am I not Santa?
I like how this is...
It's literally almost Christmas, what do you mean?
It's like five days till Christmas!
Merry Christmas!
Senpai!
Senpai, I'm late for school!
Oh no.
Oh my god.
I might die, actually.
Novelty.
Oh my god.
What exactly did they update?
What do you mean?
They updated stuff, so what exactly did they update?
Have you played this game before?
Mint said they updated this game, that's why we're playing it.
What?
They added multiplayer.
Multiplayer?
Oh my god!
Merry Christmas!
Oh my god, there's so much stuff.
How do I become a different character?
Click the avatar when you hit TAB.
Mac supplier.
I can teleport, I can kick you guys because I'm a server leader.
No, don't do it!
Wait, we can be fast food girls again.
That's fantastic.
Yeah, that's fine.
Here we go, everybody!
I am the sky.
I have a present for you guys.
What's this?
It's my present.
Mr. Beats.
Guys, Merry Christmas!
What is it?
It's nothing, it's just a box.
I'm gonna put this...
It's not the best present of them all, it's just a box.
Wait, oh my god!
Why are you so squeamish?
Oh my god, that's what happens when you crouch?
Yeah, that's what happens when you crouch!
This is how crouching works!
Oh wait, I can stand on top of you!
What?
Snuffy crouch, snuffy crouch, I wanna see what crouching is.
Control, left control.
Why does this look like a cigarette?
What the fuck is a pollutant?
Stop stabbing me with it.
It's just a chill guy.
Oh, is it?
Is it the devil's lettuce?
Is this the devil's lettuce?
No, it's not.
What is that?
Is that like a fire?
Snuffy, why are you laughing about it then?
Well, I was the cigarette guy, I just said he's a chill guy.
We can't stand the Christmas trees back up, they're just stuck here now.
No you can't, you press 4 and then you click on it.
I wanna make a really fast...
We should have like a competition, like who makes the most festive looking...
You want me to do something other than spawn in stupid amounts of things and then link it all together and try and crash my own computer?
That sounds dumb, I'm not sure about that idea.
It's the best idea.
How do you put stuff in the ground?
How do I make funny shapes?
That's when I spawned them and it said spawn static and it seemed to work.
Why is this one locked?
Fear of the dark.
I like how you can hold the rockets as they're going off, this seems very dangerous.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, I know, right?
Let's light them up.
Wait, I'm gonna connect them.
No, wait!
Oh my god, wake up, rocket jump!
I don't know where they go!
We were all dead at the end, you get...
Oh my god, y'all got blown away.
I'm on the other side of town!
What happened to the gas station?
Why is the pump all fucked up?
I blew it up.
You blew it up?
You can blow up houses and stuff?
Wait, can you actually?
I think I need to framerate cap this game.
Dude, I'm on top of the Everest!
Oh my god, I stink!
Did you guys hear about how Mount Everest is getting too stinky because people are just leaving their poop on the mountain?
Also, they're leaving their dead bodies up there.
Apparently, Mount Everest became such a tourist destination for people that there's a conga line to climb the mountain.
I feel like that's...
The scariest thing about Everest is the line that you get of just like, try not to freeze to death while you wait in line.
No, but then...
The government has literally made a PSA to be like, please carry your poop back down the mountain.
Because the mountain is getting really fucking stinky now.
We need you to carry it down.
Is that a thing?
Do you have to like, pack it up somewhere?
I don't know professional hiking.
Yeah, because if you leave it on the mountain, it's there forever.
Yeah, but that's just living.
You can poop on the outside and that should be okay.
What happens if you set fireworks off inside of this house?
That's what I'm about to do, baby.
Well, actually, I'm smoking these people out of their house.
Oh my god, there's a pizza on the roof!
Wait, this is the freaking bat house!
I'm literally at the freaking bat house!
There's a pizza on the roof!
Look, look where I am, guys!
Smoke bomb!
Ninja!
Warrior!
Oh wait, you're right in this house.
Jesus Christ!
Oh wait, you're in this house!
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
Are you alive?
I'm okay!
What happened?
I actually threw down the house!
What did you do?
I threw down the firework store, you guys!
You blew up the firework store?
There's nothing left?
There's literally nothing left?
You live with yourself after that.
The sign is over here!
It's the only thing that's left!
Holy shit, God!
Oh my god!
My eyes!
I can't see!
It was so bright!
I didn't realize you could burn stuff down!
Snuffy, you know what was amazing?
I rounded the corner and there was just this gingerbread man illuminated by the fire with only fucking destruction.
It was so hard.
It was like that meme of that little girl looking back after she left that pretty house.
I didn't think it would work but they just started catching each other.
Oh my god!
I want to try it now.
I'm going to the church.
Oh my god!
I did wonder, because you were silent for a while.
I was like, what is she doing?
It would have taken a long time to build this.
I was like, you guys were like, I'm going to blow up a house so I was like, yeah, let me walk into one of these places and see what they got.
And I was like, oh, a fire restore.
Can I actually light up the display fire?
Wait, do you have a propane tank?
Can you actually light something and hit the propane tank and have it explode?
The fireworks came, but instead we just started lighting propane tanks inside people's houses.
This is much more interesting.
Mint, mint.
Yeah?
Are you committing arson in the church?
My wedding is not ready yet.
Would you like some help?
I can add some stuff.
I'm going to make sure.
I want to see if it lights the propane tank.
It warns us when you spawn so many items in a short period of time.
It's like, by the way, Joki just spawned 10 items within 3 seconds.
I know.
Joki, it says that only you can access blueprints.
I don't know if it's something fun, but it says you can do blueprints.
Can you?
It sounds like a war.
Guys, you can light a propane tank, by the way.
It exploded in front of me.
It's all gone.
Are we going to have a...
Are you guys performing the nativity scene?
A scene, yeah.
I made Mary out of doom booms.
Where are you guys?
Come to the church!
There's a church?
Yeah, well, there won't be him anymore.
What does a church look like?
Why are there shells?
Are these shotgun shells?
What do these do?
Oh, I see.
I see the church.
I can't tell if they're going to blow up each other because they're in proximity.
Is that what happened with you, Snuffy?
Yeah, I just lit up a few in the whole building.
I just got a slowdown notification.
Alright, guys.
Slowdown notification.
Baby fireworks.
This is so real.
Oh my god!
Are these real propane tanks?
I've reached the limit of how many fireworks I can spawn in the game.
It was 50.
I gave you guys 50.
Well, I've reached that limit!
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm throwing some in here.
What makes a lot of fun?
Mail toes.
Mail toes?
Mail toes and some lady fingers?
Oh, I get it.
Lady fingers and mail toes.
Wait, give me the lady fingers.
Oh, I reached my limit too.
Alright.
Let me do some rockets.
We'll do some strobolicious.
I got it.
I reached my limit.
Wait, did you spawn in these tanks?
Wait, you can just spawn in propane tanks.
Yeah, you can.
That's what I did.
I literally just spawned in propane tanks.
It's a novelty.
It's not even included in the fireworks.
I can spawn more than I can fireworks.
Yeah, because it's a prop.
I don't know why they add propane tanks in a prop category.
I enjoy the fact that we played a fireworks game and it took us less than 30 minutes for us to just put 500 propane tanks If you think about it, propane tank is like a bigger firework.
If you think about it.
We're going for the movie scene.
It's like a firework on the ground.
Alright, are we ready to light it up?
Alright, Mint, give us a sermon.
What the fuck is this?
We're gathered here to give thanks to the lord of explosions because we surely do love them.
It's going to be like the fucking kingdom scene right here.
Amen!
Can I get a hallelujah?
Hallelujah!
You don't get to survive this.
Light it up!
I'm stuck behind the mountains.
I ended up on the top of the mountain.
I can see you.
Hallelujah!
I heard there was a sacred horn that David played and it pleased the lord.
Praise the lord!
Praise thee!
Oh my god.
What is this?
There's just so much smoke too.
They really encapsulate that smoke that lingers.
I know.
Oh my god.
The church is still standing somehow.
The inside is kind of fogged.
They didn't add any physics to the front part.
We blew it up so hard the pool next door lost all the water.
Oh my god.
I like how the fireworks...
Can you hear the objects colliding?
No.
Oh, I can hear it, yeah.
I'm unlocked.
Wait, you can unlock items.
What'd you unlock?
Wait, there's some level of physics.
If I throw this wood at the church, the pieces of it move.
Oh, not that one though.
Not the windows.
The windows stayed.
Pick up.
That is real.
The windows are still there.
Pick up.
Why can't I pick up?
You press 2.
It's telling me E.
How do I unlock things?
Press 2.
Oh, like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are you okay?
She's being transformed.
Oh my god.
Smoke.
How do I unlock stuff?
You see this dog house?
There's a question mark in there.
Oh.
I...
Ninja transformed in the smoke.
Why is it moving?
I just picked it up.
I just decided to throw it.
No unlock for you.
I don't need any of this.
Screw it.
There was a question mark in that dog house and I unlocked a new firework.
I got this french fry for you.
Oh, so we gotta go find other fireworks.
Wait, I wanna see if Germantown is still available.
Oh, maybe us exploding buildings is good because maybe there's secrets inside them.
Yeah, exactly.
So we should spawn more propainting.
Someone should check if Germantown of 125 mods is free now.
No!
What are we gonna boot?
Are we booting up 125 Germantown mods?
They have 125 mods!
I can't even imagine what kind of mods...
You guys join first just in case half the mods are dicks.
Yeah.
I'm the host, I can't leave.
I'm just gonna blow up this house.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I'm just gonna start blowing up the houses.
I wanna see what's in the house.
They didn't let me in.
Oh!
What happened?
You good?
Are you okay over there?
What did you use?
What on earth did you do?
What did you do?
Propain.
Where do you find the propain at?
Oh, I see it.
Yeah, baby.
Where's the secret fireworks, guys?
What do we need?
Secret fireworks.
I was promised secret fireworks.
Here we go.
What are you guys doing?
Let's blow it up.
I reached the limit.
No more?
No more already?
I can't spawn anymore propain?
You gotta light it up.
You have to light it up to get rid of it.
There isn't any.
How is the house still standing?
Other than like maybe a bunch of them just got...
Oh wait, did they get knocked out into the world?
Wait, oh my god.
There's just lingering propain.
Oh yeah, maybe half the fireworks you spawned at first are in the mountains now.
I'm gonna clear all the props out.
The feds are here.
Oh my god, it's you.
What are you doing, lady?
You committing crime?
No.
Are you guys trying to commit some crime?
Excuse me, Mr. Ginger.
No officer, I would never...
No officer.
I heard some noise.
I got calls about a noise complaint here, ladies.
No.
You happen to be responsible.
What are all of these?
This is my inhaler.
My inhaler.
One non-propane, maybe, to blow it all up.
The disturbance of peace.
Let's do the cakes.
What other avatars do they have?
There's an avatar that's literally called City Gamer Girl.
I know, it's so funny.
I think it's like that Twitch...
The Twitch actress.
Twitch Purple.
Yeah, it's the Twitch Purple.
Hey, I gotta get my propane to explode.
Why will it not?
I don't know.
You just light it.
You have to light it up.
You hold it and then you light it up.
Goodbye, gas station.
Oh, I think it worked.
Oh my God.
Oh my God!
I know exactly where you guys are.
There's like...
Sequential, there's just house after house.
I took out the gas station.
Why don't my places catch on fire?
I don't know.
We can see what you're doing.
Maybe we gotta see what you're doing wrong.
Yeah.
I'm not a good pyromaniac.
Show us your method.
Okay, let's go blow up the grocery store.
Choose your house.
A grocery store?
Yeah, there's a grocery store.
Wait, wait, wait.
Should we restart the map and then specifically put a bunch of propane in the fireworks display?
Because that was big by itself.
So if we then dump...
Everyone puts propane in the fireworks display.
Oh, what is that?
Wait, what?
What is this?
What happened?
I don't know, I found it on the side.
This is the mascot for the fireworks store.
I'm really tiny now, by the way.
You're so tiny.
I'll have to restart the server.
Why are you so small?
Then we can drop 200 propane tanks in the fireworks place.
Okay.
I'm gonna take a whiz break really quick.
Oh my god, another German server.
What map was that, Ducky?
Oh, there's a Norway server now!
Hell yeah.
Okay, that was the city town.
Oh, okay.
Alright, do we want the same map?
We want the same map, right?
I think we specifically want to blow up that damn map.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, I'll put 150 fireworks limit now.
Oh god, 150 each?
In the fireworks?
Yeah!
I like how this was supposed to be a fireworks sim, but instead we just found the propane tanks.
And we're using them to explode buildings?
That's much more important.
I like to sprinkle in some fireworks for show.
Yeah, cause it has a nice little halo above it as you blow up a building.
Yeah, it's like a big...
Alright, let's see...
It's king of the hill sim.
Alright, where is it?
Where's the place?
It was where the smoldering fireball was earlier, so it's over this way.
Oh, you sent a new one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it's over this way.
Sorry guys, I'm now looking.
Also, you're... Wait, there's a server called Doki and Mint Kissing.
Ok, I did not...
That's actually a new server, cause I nearly did not see that server in my list.
Alright.
Ok, I'm back.
I am propaining.
Dang it.
I hope I didn't miss anything.
No, you're good, you're good.
Yeah, put the server code.
Wait, where is the fireworks store?
You guys blew it up before I could see what it looked like.
Wait, it's not...
Do you remember where the smoldering fireball was the first time Snuffy blew something up?
It's there.
Oh, I found it.
Yeah, oh, Cody's fireworks.
Wait, that side was...
That was the sign that's on the house.
Yeah.
I thought it was like a welcome board on the ground.
I feel like if we all do this, we might actually crush the server and it's gonna be glorious.
Yeah, crush the server!
I'm gonna fall over and die.
I got the red propane.
Also, the red looks like it's scarier.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I just saw like a tiny, tiny Snuffy running through the...
I like how it says props, but it's...
Who left this child here?
I'll do some rockets.
This is what you get for being on the naughty list.
Let me make it a little bit patriotic as well.
Oh my god, it's so...
Wait, we should...
Guys, we have 150 props and 150 fireworks, so you can add more fireworks later.
Make sure when you specifically light the propane tanks, because when I lit a firework near the propane tank, it didn't work.
Yeah, you have to light the propane tank itself.
Yeah, propane tank itself.
We should save this too, and then if we want to spawn...
I can barely walk, there's so many propane tanks.
You need to spawn in it instead.
This is like we're filling up a fish enclosure.
We're just like the pebbles.
Viper, viper.
I haven't reached the limit yet.
Me neither.
Propane tank yet.
You know what, I'm just gonna spam, spam, spam...
Spam, spam, spam...
Oh, slow tank.
Yeah, I got the slow tank.
Wait, wait, wait.
But now I can fill it up.
Now I can fill it up with fireworks.
There's still 50.
Wait, why is there just this one corner with nothing in it?
Yeah, there's this one corner with nothing.
Oh, here, I'll come get it.
We got this area filled with fireworks.
Fill it up, fill it up.
We got strobolicious.
Strobolicious fireworks.
I can still spawn in propane.
Guys, this is...
Oh, propane and fireworks are separate, so...
Yeah, you need 50 fireworks and 150 props, dude.
We're layering this like a sandwich.
Oh, I've reached the limit, I've reached the limit.
I'm in the corner.
Okay.
Oh my God, I can't even go through this area anymore.
I'm stuck.
Do we wanna be inside or do we wanna be outside?
Do we want someone to have the outside perspective?
Okay, I call...
For the sake of my PC, I'm gonna be outside.
Okay.
But you're not even streaming.
Chat, which do you want?
Oh, wait, you're outside perspective.
Do you wanna be inside or outside, chat?
Which do you want?
I'll be outside because I was already inside for this explosion one time.
Okay, I'll stay inside then.
I'll sit on this lovely chair and you guys go ahead and just...
I see a lot of outsides, okay.
I found a fairly isolated propane tank.
Do you want me to light this one?
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, we ready?
No, no, wait, I'm adding a little bit.
I'm adding Thick Billy in here.
Okay.
Who is that?
Who is this?
What is this?
You can add a person?
No, no, it's a name of a fire.
Oh my god, we can just add a man in the middle.
Wait, we can put the snowman.
We can put the snowman.
And then one Christmas tree.
I'm stuck, I'm stuck again.
One flamingo.
Do not barricade yourselves in.
Are you ready?
I need to clean this up a little bit.
Oh my god, I'm lagging already.
I think being inside is pretty epic.
It's... okay.
If I can get inside...
Mint, you can blow up with me if you want.
Alright, I'll light one too.
Let me know when you're ready.
Alright, I'm ready.
Who will stay inside?
It's been nice knowing you all.
Why do you have a stopwatch with you?
It's a countdown timer.
Alright, let's hope this works.
I'm going to light this thing now.
Godspeed everybody.
Here we go!
Oh my god!
It's so beautiful!
The second wing!
Oh my god!
I like how half of them went off on the corner of town because all the fireworks got blown the fuck out there.
Don't worry, there's still more.
There's still more!
The slowdown!
There was like a slowdown.
They all started coming at me like an action movie.
It was so awesome.
I'm going to be sick.
Merry Christmas everybody!
Where did everybody end up?
There are a lot of buildings on fire.
I think it's over.
Yeah, we're good, we're good.
It's so smoky.
I can't even see.
Honestly, the game handled that pretty well.
I think I did pretty well.
What the fuck?
I heard a noise.
I heard there was a disturbance in the area.
Come and see what I found.
Wait, where are you?
I'm behind the fireworks store.
Half the propane tanks seem to merge into a gigantic caterpillar.
Do you see it here?
No, I don't see it.
It's a giant propane caterpillar!
I see your snowman.
Let me take a screenshot.
Shall I see if they're still real?
I could blow them up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What the fuck?
What?
Are they real?
I don't think they're real.
Oh my god!
It looks like a big...
That's long.
No, they're not real.
Can I pick one up?
No, I can't even pick one up.
They're not real.
Let me show you guys.
Wait, I mean...
I have Limoon chat, so you guys can probably see it.
But in case you can't, this is Limoon's.
Hey look, the snowman survived, guys.
Where did the Christmas tree go?
Where did the snowman...
Oh, it's over there.
I see it.
It's all the way over there.
Where are you?
I'm where we were...
Where we found the centipede.
I was just there.
There's a Christmas tree right there.
Yes, see it?
Oh no, I think maybe the objects have all gotten fucked up.
I think so too.
Because I'm like...
I don't see anything.
Sorry guys, I didn't take my meds today.
Sorry.
Don't take my meds.
Everywhere I look, I see the Christmas tree.
It's like it follows, but...
It's a Christmas tree.
Wait, I found another hidden thing.
If we want to get it.
Another unlockable.
Oh, yes please.
It's at the tree house.
You know where the tree house is?
Yeah, I'm at the tree house.
No, you're not.
You're running on a fence.
We're at a tree house right here.
Definitely not real.
There must be multiple tree houses.
No, I see it.
I don't see any of you at the tree house.
What the fuck?
We're not at the tree house.
We're at Doki running on a fence.
Doki is like lagging out.
I think we actually did break the server.
She's got the burden on her shoulders.
She's like, I'm at the tree house.
Wait, wait, you guys.
It's like I died and I'm a ghost right now.
You have to open up some of the stream.
Because you're literally... you won't move.
You're just running in place on a fence right now.
I'm like a ghost right now.
Is it just me or does this cop avatar have a really bad case of lordosis?
What is lordosis?
It's where his back is curved and then his ass is sticking out.
He's dead, bro.
He's got that curve-alicious.
I'm a ghost looking at what happened to what my life was gonna be like after I died.
Why are you so small, Mint?
Why are you both so small?
There's a baby.
We're the baby version.
Yeah, yeah, be the girl and boy rather than woman and man.
There you go.
You're so freaking scary and I'm dating you.
You're so fucked up.
Am I a gingerbread man at least?
Yeah, you're a gingerbread man.
But I'm still running in place.
Stop spawning this Christmas tree.
This Christmas tree has a dick now.
How do we get into the treehouse?
I don't know how.
It's really high up.
What if we just blow it up?
Okay, let's do it.
It's the only thing we know how to do.
Wait, guys, I think we can parkour it.
You wanna parkour?
Instead of just exploding it?
Where's your sense of adventure?
Parkouring is more adventurous than blowing something up.
What do you mean?
They're presents under the Christmas tree.
You are being very strategic about this.
I appreciate that.
There, look, see?
Parkour.
They're presents under the Christmas tree.
I'll add some presents.
Yeah, because your game is glitched.
You're not here.
I'm trying to fix her.
Insert them into the tree a little bit.
This is the tree of life and propane.
Oh, great propane tree.
Wait, wait.
I'm gonna add some...
You can parkour up using propane tanks.
No way!
I think so.
Oh my god, you're doing it!
We need to strategically place them.
Or we can still blow it up.
We could still blow it up.
Let's just blow it up.
I liked your strategy, Limu, but...
Wait, there's one called Amazing Granny.
Wait, wait, wait.
It's literally Matara.
Except the amazing part.
Guys, you know we can spawn in a little box, guys?
Like, we could...
I love that Doki can just spawn stuff in, but I can't even see her, so she's just like literal God being like...
A box for you, Matara.
I've given my kids a box.
What happened?
I just got sent to space.
It looks like the tree is explosion-proof, maybe?
I can't fucking see, it's so smoky in here.
I can't see, it's so smoky.
Guys, I got it!
Oh no.
Oh wait, your box has survived.
I told you.
I told you the box strat works.
Are you transform-icing this right now?
Doki's our shaman, let's go.
How did you get in?
I just parkoured.
Jesus Christ, you are so good at this game.
Okay, it's only a smoke bomb yellow.
I get bounced off of the branch to the left.
When I try.
Yeah, I get bounced off.
I can freeze it.
When you get up there, you have to crouch to walk in.
I can freeze the box.
Wait, wait, wait.
I can give you an elevator.
Stand on the box.
Stand on top of one of the boxes.
I'm on one.
You're not, you're floating for me.
Where are you?
Are you still on the...
You're floating on... oh, there, there, there.
Did you use the elevator?
Okay, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Doki's acting like she's one of the team.
Santa's not real.
There's no Santa here.
Bro thinks he's part of the team.
Are you still here?
Can we blow you up, maybe?
Let's try blowing you up.
I think she makes this fence invincible.
Because I couldn't blow it up when she was here.
Maybe you're just not trying hard enough.
Merry Christmas!
Merry freaking Christmas, Santa Claus.
Merry freaking Christmas.
God, it's like a wonderful life.
Guys, please, I'm alive!
This will free her.
You'll be free after this.
I can't pick a single thing to...
Goodbye, cruel world.
I don't know about you guys, but my cramping tanks are now like spawning.
They're fixed in position.
They no longer have physics, they just kind of spawn in the air.
Oh yeah, mine too.
I think the server's way broken.
She's still there.
Should we try a different town then?
Yeah, Donkey, you're stuck.
Different map.
We can be a whole different town.
Exciting.
New things to blow up.
New fireworks stars to find.
Oh my god, wait, there's so many new mods.
Okay, don't join the 195 mod team.
Did you guys ever have a pyromania phase?
I heard that's very popular for people to go through a phase when you're growing up.
Is that you become like a pyromaniac for a little bit.
What?
Okay, tell us your story.
Is that not a thing?
I don't think that's a phase, right?
I swear, it's a phase that you're like, yeah.
We can set up a roleplay server and have money so somebody can buy fireworks.
How do you do that?
It's in the workshop.
I'm downloading mods.
Oh, we're getting mods?
Oh my god.
Yeah, we're getting mods.
I got the Xmas mod.
There's a German village.
Do we have to subscribe too?
Presumably not.
Yeah, I think we can just download them as we go in like a Garry's Mod server or something.
Christmas characters, do the Christmas characters.
Okay, yeah, I did it.
There's Olaf in there.
And the creepy gnome.
Okay, I added something.
I added a mod in there.
This looks so fun.
Oh, there's the ski resort.
Wait, there's a Minecraft mod?
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
Yeah, I added it.
I subscribed to it.
There's a lot of shit in here.
Fireworks store props, oh no.
There's literally 65.
I'm not gonna look through 65 pages.
That's way too many.
Wait, wait, there's like pop by popular.
I'm gonna get the update popularity.
What is the most popular one?
That's what I was looking at.
Doki, apparently there's an iconic character pack and you can be Shrek.
That was the one I literally subscribed to.
I was like...
Hell yeah, hell yeah.
People are making like actual fireworks and not like memes and stuff.
It's kind of impressive.
I've downloaded maybe five different nuke mods.
I'm just gonna let you guys pick whatever.
Okay, I got it.
I even added real... I added money into the mod too.
Wait, so we're gonna have to pay for stuff?
Yeah, I'll be the clerk.
Welcome to capitalism.
I'm gonna reproduce capitalism into this game.
Wait, can you get the realistic nuke mod?
Oh, there's a Wild West one too.
How cute.
I got something really funny.
Okay, let me get the code.
Boo.
What the fuck?
There's a statue of Liberty here.
I'm joining.
It's like low FPS?
Yeah, but I don't think lowering the quality is gonna help.
I think it's just that we fucking nuked this area.
Yeah, we're trying to blow this game up, literally.
It's about blowing things up, but we're trying to push this limit.
We're just a bunch of girls, you know.
We just can't help ourselves with spawning in 500 per minute.
The feminine urge to spawn in 200 per minute.
Loading Minecraft mod map.
Let's go!
Loading mods!
Oh, look at all the mods loading!
What have I got here?
Oh my god!
Scooby Doo!
Gross!
Oh my god, it's Benjamin Babbitt!
He's here!
I heard you guys were a fan.
Wow, there's so many!
Oh my god, I'm Olaf.
Look at the statue of Liberty!
There's literally a fucking statue of Liberty!
Ew, why does Scooby look like that?
Why is there a statue of Liberty?
Oh my god!
Wait, I'm not seeing them.
Oh, I see them now.
They're like...
Oh shit, it's Otto!
Oh my god!
Guys, we're in GTA, guys!
Oh shit, here we go again!
Oh my god, I wish there was emote dances and stuff.
There probably is like 195 plus monsters.
Oh god, why is the Shrek so textured?
I'm moving really slowly as well.
Holy shit.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I can do it!
I'm stomping!
Oh my god!
Why is it raining money?
It's for me!
I told you the money was like...
I just bought a bunch of dollars.
Oh my god, there's 500 euros!
I got the big bucks, yeah!
500 euros, baby!
I'm picking it all up.
Eat it on the floor, eat it on the floor.
And lick it up.
Lick it up!
Wait, can you guys tell which one is the real one?
Can you guys tell?
Yeah, the one with the...
Yeah, that one's Herobrine.
That one's literally Herobrine, isn't it?
Unless that's the pupils.
Yeah, it's just guys...
Oh yeah, it's just brown eyes.
Wow.
I'm gonna blow up Minecraft.
Oh my god, you're gonna blow up Minecraft?
You're gonna be a creeper.
Wait, where's the creeper?
Wait, do you think we could be creepers?
Oh, I have to go back and pick this.
I'm going to go through a bunch of propane at the base of the Statue of Liberty.
Yeah, I was about to literally...
Wow, that was beautiful.
That was beautiful.
Now make 50 more of them.
It looks very well structured.
Is it gonna work?
It'll work.
I'm inside.
Oh god.
This is too much like Minecraft.
I'm stuck in the...
I cannot get up these steps with Shrek.
I'm stuck in the Minecraft.
Oh no.
Where are you?
Because I'm stuck in the Minecraft.
Oh there we go.
Are you guys gonna blow up the Statue of Liberty?
Yeah.
Here we are.
Sounds like a Nicolas Cage problem.
The Declaration of Independence.
We're gonna steal it to stop them from stealing it.
Oh gosh, getting up these steps.
They're not automatic.
Oh my god.
No, I was like jumping them.
I was striking, it was awful.
Serious, my worst enemy.
Alright, time to put them all at the base.
Well, it goes all the way up, Mint.
I don't know if you wanna put them like in this room here.
I don't feel like you can blow...
I think it's aesthetic so you can see the fireworks next to the Statue of Liberty.
Yeah, I'm not sure this is going to explode and that makes me very sad.
Wait, how do you...
Oh, there's stairs out here.
Oh my god, there's more stairs?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
This game feels cathartic, honestly.
This is so nice.
This is like axe throwing but for my brain.
Do any of the...
Oh, we got Christmas lights now.
That's cute.
I love the names of fireworks.
Do any of the Minecraft buildings blow up?
Wait, this map is so big.
There's more behind the village.
Oh, hello.
There's more stuff behind the village, guys.
This is actually crazy.
Is this as far as it goes?
Like towards the...
Yeah, if you go behind...
If you go like the opposite side from the Statue of Liberty...
There's like an entire like...
Terrain up here.
Let's just try, Lime.
All we can do.
I'm spreading propane tanks.
Wait, where are you guys?
How long do I just keep running and like...
Getting lost in Minecraft...
Before I find you guys.
Yeah, go to the Statue of Liberty.
Oh my god, I was going the opposite way.
I like how we said...
We're gonna blow up the Statue of Liberty and you're like...
I wonder where they could be.
You guys are a genius.
Oh, we can use the boxes to go up.
Oh.
Yeah.
I'm going to rock the foundations though.
I'm building.
I don't expect it to work.
Yeah.
I feel like...
It's very...
We all know in Minecraft...
The structures are very...
Strong in Minecraft.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to do this.
It's like all made out of bedrock or some shit.
Don't mind me.
I'm trying to build.
I like how there's just a trail of propane tanks.
Follow the trail of propane tanks, guys.
Follow the trail.
All the arsonists are here, are they?
I'm going to use the bathroom while...
I know you guys are going to take a while putting all these propane tanks.
I'm going to use the bathroom.
This is going to be the greatest...
The greatest heist ever known to man.
Which is the biggest firework?
OK.
I made it to the base.
It looks like a bunch of corn dogs.
Oh my god.
I don't have a nuke.
I literally don't have one called nuke.
Wait, where is hyper-realistic nuke?
I downloaded like five of those mods.
Oh, I think maybe because Doki...
Doki didn't download a singular bomb?
Wow.
There's now a box called fuck you.
What?
I'm going to put fuck you in here.
Where do you see that?
It's under...
Cakes?
Yeah, it's under cakes.
Cakes.
Oh wow, look at these.
Wow, bloody Mary.
Painted sky.
Like the smooth criminals.
This one's called wrap.
Oh, it's so tiny.
Yeah, fuck you's kinda small.
Sam's gone.
This one's called gladiator 60 italian style.
This one's got bears on it.
Oh, it's really small too.
Donder slag.
What?
I like donder slag.
Donder slag extra.
This is why all the German people play it.
Yeah.
Maybe they have a lot of fireworks.
We're adding all the fireworks in.
My framerate is already suffering.
I know, me too.
Funky honey badger.
Honey badger.
I'm going to add some more propane tanks.
Actually, I'll do 2024, even though it's almost 2025.
Happy 2024, everybody.
Oh yeah.
Happy new year.
I like how the italian style firework just looks like a cigar that you spawn.
I'm going to add a world stopper because it sounds intense.
Monster?
Yeah, I've been spawning a bunch of those.
What is that?
What about this one?
This one's called sphinx.
Yeah, sphinx looks pretty cool.
It's a fountain though, so I don't think it'll blow up.
It'll just swoosh a little bit.
It's okay, I'll add more tanks.
I'll do some tall sphinx.
This one's called NATO.
I'm spawning it.
Yeah.
More.
Limelicious currently has 100 spawned fireworks in the game.
Stop fucking... you snitch.
Calling you out.
I'm down to 40 frames if I accidentally nudge a physics object.
There's like so many tiny objects and stuff he has put in the air that I'm colliding with every single one of them.
Those are the fireworks.
Did you just put them down?
So what if I put down 500 different iterations of Gladiator 60 Italian style cigar?
I'm letting propane fall from the heavens too.
I have noticed a few things have come down and almost hit me on the head.
Oh, sorry.
That's me.
Okay.
Alright, I hit my limit.
I have not yet hit my limit.
When Stokey's back we can do it.
Oh, this one's called Strobilicious.
I feel like I'm contractually obliged to actually spawn that one.
Strobilicious for Mimelicious.
Hell yeah.
Wait, the map is so big and beautiful from up here.
Like a voluptuous woman.
Now light her up.
Love those.
Give her the lighter.
I think we're waiting for Doki.
Yeah, wait for Doki.
A big reveal.
I don't think the statue is going to blow up.
I feel like I should sit like a movie with an unlit cigarette in my mouth but I'm standing just close enough to the explosion that it will light it just by the sparks flying.
Yeah.
So badass.
What is this material?
I think it's wool.
Why would you make the Statue of Liberty out of wool and not diamonds?
Because she's soft on the outside.
Oh my god.
She's soft.
See, I told you.
She's a beautiful woman.
She's made of copper which is a very...
It's not as beautiful.
You okay?
I'm okay.
Doki, I want to light these fireworks now.
Yeah, Doki, hurry up.
Doki!
The pyromaniacs are suffering!
There's hundreds of explosives rigged up to blow and I have to stand here.
Lime, do you see me?
Yes, I see you.
Are you up on the top up there?
Yeah.
I'm up here.
I've got the zoom out.
The zoom out?
Wait, what do you mean?
I want to see it.
Oh, I see you!
Let me become the bigger...
Oh, I'm Olaf.
I'm like Olaf with his mouth just like...
gaping open.
That's kind of terrifying.
Seeing you in the middle of the forest like that.
Scooby's nose.
I hate that.
It's so scary.
Can you imagine it's dark at night and you look across the field and that's just fucking scary?
I have a picture like that.
In Akiba, there's like this one little alleyway and there's a Olaf, like full-size Olaf costume that has been there for years.
This is so terrifying.
I have a picture.
Oh, God.
Not the two...
like the old and overly loved...
Yeah!
Let's explode it!
Blow it up!
We're gonna blow it up!
I'm still inside the building.
Light it up!
Here we go!
Goodbye, Statue of Liberty!
What?
Oh, no!
I blew up the map.
I'm in the void.
No!
And our flag was still there.
She's indestructible, everybody!
I'm tiny!
This is what I saw.
Where are you in the void?
I have no perspective anymore.
I've fallen so far I can't see the map.
I'm still falling.
Look at the chat, guys.
How did you guys get tiny?
Look at the chat.
This is what I saw.
Tiny!
Let me see.
It's beautiful.
It's kind of poetic, honestly.
Just love watching it all burn.
He's tired.
No more winter.
Is there an unstuck button?
I don't think there is.
I don't think I'm going to do it today.
I'm coming to get you, Lime!
Yeah, let's rescue Lime!
Fireworks for you in the abyss!
Can you spawn shit in the abyss?
I can spawn stuff in the abyss!
Where are you?
I'm signaling to you with my flame.
My flame is lit!
Wait, do you see my flame too?
I'm in the void with you!
There's a respawn button.
I see a flame flickering in and out.
Let me spin around in circles.
It's beautiful.
I'm sorry, I did not know that.
How do you respawn?
I love Christmas!
I'm giving you Christmas.
I want single bells.
Jingle bells!
We should play this while we light up the statue.
I'm kind of disappointed it didn't blow up though.
Can we spawn only green and red?
And see if we can do like...
Hundreds of Christmas...
Mail toes?
Wait, can we blow this guy up?
He's a mapper green.
No, you can't blow him up.
I don't think anything in this world is destructible.
What is this though?
This guy got blown up.
Oh my god, he did!
He's in pieces!
He's fully intact for me.
Oh yeah, this guy too.
No you can't!
We committed murder today.
Who did we kill?
We killed a Minecraft villager.
Look over here!
Come here!
I can't even kill the...
I can't kill the zombie.
This guy is definitely alive.
Is he alive on your screen?
What about this one?
I don't know about this guy.
I think he's...
Yeah, I think he's a god.
Do we have a doctor in the house?
Do we have a doctor in Minecraft?
Why is the music so loud?
This map is huge!
Merry Christmas!
Merry Christmas everybody!
Happy Holidays!
You guys want me to download another map?
Yes!
Yeah, give us some realistic nukes!
I'm watching the server guys!
I wanna get realistic nukes!
Alright, where is the realistic nuke?
I have like five of them.
Do you want me to load the server?
Oh, I found it!
Is that it?
Yeah, give us the Breaking Bad characters too.
I thought I downloaded it.
I'm pretty sure I did, but...
There's realistic humans?
There's like traffic codes.
Oh, this is snow!
We can do snow weather.
Did I not download Breaking Bad?
Oh, I did it!
Okay, I got Breaking Bad.
There's 7.6k people that downloaded Breaking Bad.
Probably good then.
What's pre-loaded packings?
Is it all together?
What is this?
What is the fucking...
Oh, can you get the Spray Mania?
Can you get the Spray Mania?
Spray Mania?
Yeah, sure.
I'll download that too.
Oh, color explodes!
Yeah, looks cool.
That looks cool.
Okay, I got the Breaking Bad characters.
Let's see...
I like how...
German city district...
Has 9.3k...
1000 people...
What the fuck?
Why is it all German?
I don't understand.
Why is it so popular in Germany?
Alright, let's see...
Maybe fireworks are banned there.
So this is all they got.
They have Rick and Morty garage map.
Cloudsdale for my little pony!
Cloudsdale!
Oh my god, do it, please!
Please!
It's the newest mods, I'm scared.
Mint's out here like, I wanna blow up my little pony!
There's a Rick and Morty garage map!
Rick and Morty!
Oh my god.
They have one called Winter Kingdom.
There's the moon!
Let's blow up the moon!
I'd subscribe to Cloudsdale.
Nice!
Oh god!
Oh, there's some sort of...
Tomorrow Mania is like a circus one.
And there's Wild West.
I like how there's literally a green screen.
There's a green screen map!
Yeah, this is actually my side hustle.
I go and record a bunch of HD pictures of green screen fireworks and then sell them individually as graphics.
For those who need to use it for their videos Ew!
There's a fast food mod but the picture is horrible.
What is this?
It's like spaghetti croquet.
What is that?
Ew!
Oh, I saw Cloudsdale.
Oh my god, please.
Don't worry guys, I downloaded the Gamer Girls mod for you guys.
Just for you guys.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Wait, there's a Simpsons map.
There is, yeah.
But it's hidden run.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know if it's a good map because it's hidden run.
I don't know if there's like inside.
Because the hidden run is mostly just outside.
Right, right.
That's fair.
Alright, let's see.
Is there anything else you want me to download?
There's just Arizona.
Those are...
They miss Arizona.
They just really miss Arizona.
I really specifically want to set fireworks off in Arizona.
I don't know why.
It's just something I've wanted to do my entire life.
There's a Predators pack?
The fuck?
Oh, it's just a firework company named Predators.
I was like, the fuck is a Predators pack?
There's a moon map.
Yeah, yeah, that's what I was saying.
We could blow up the moon.
I downloaded the fast food mod.
You see it, right?
What is that?
It's literally a picture of a fast food.
Wait, there's an abandoned asylum.
I think this is a phasmophobia asylum.
Alright, I'm setting up this.
I'm going to create the server.
Alright, do we want Cloudsdale?
Rick and Morty Garage?
That's the two I downloaded.
Cloudsdale, right?
We want to blow up Cloudsdale.
Did you download Poopsmoke?
Okay, why do you want Poopsmoke?
Why wouldn't you want Poopsmoke?
Why do you want that?
Alright, I downloaded Poopsmoke just for you.
Just because you asked for it.
Okay, come back.
I ran out of toilet paper.
Oh, I guess Duffy wanted it too.
What?
What do I want?
Are you okay?
You're out of breath, girl.
I had to run all the way downstairs.
Because literally my two upstairs bathrooms don't have any toilet paper.
So I was literally just running around being like...
You know where the Poopsmoke came from.
Yeah, you know where the Poopsmoke came from.
Hey!
That was a piss only kind of run.
That was piss speed.
Okay, I don't know if we want to upset the mouse, but there is a Disney castle mod.
So...
Oh yeah, I downloaded it.
They laid off fireworks all the time.
True!
I like how we started this game...
We started this game and we were like...
Man, people mod this game?
That seems weird.
And now we're sitting here like...
No, we have this mod and this mod.
Guys, add us in this game.
Oh, that would be so cool.
I know, right?
Add us to the game.
Make us blow up.
Don't add us as avatars, add us as fireworks.
So you can let them fire.
Oh my god, guys.
This map is taking...
Cloudsdale, for some reason, is taking a very long time to load.
It just sounds like Gmod style.
I'm not even sure what it might be.
We don't even know what it looks like.
Okay, there we go.
Oh my god, I'm so excited.
Give me the code.
This is a weird map.
Wait, no.
I think Cloudsdale is broken.
It doesn't matter, it's fine.
Are we getting the...
Counter-strike source texture here?
No, Cloudsdale is mega broken.
Like, what did I load?
It's literally just...
I want to see!
No, it's not exciting.
No, I want to see!
It's not exciting.
It's called Cloudsdale.
Of course you're in the clouds.
Okay, but there usually is a city.
A city in Cloudsdale.
No, there's not.
I see the city.
Give me the code.
Okay, I'm coming in.
I'm downloading.
Okay, so you're gonna be like...
Where the fuck am I?
And then I found the actual city part.
Okay, okay.
See, you doubted it.
You doubted it and you almost made us miss out.
No, it's still not very impressive.
Doubted the majesty of Cloudsdale, what the fuck.
No, it's still not impressive.
What are you eating?
Oh, my game just...
What the hell?
It's in your mouth.
It's a cake.
I'm eating a dessert.
You got a matcha cake.
Awfully sweet.
Why do you have clouds?
I'm gonna be Batman in Cloudsdale.
Cloudsdale is taking a while to load.
Cloudsdale is huge.
I told you.
It's like huge.
It's like Cloudsdale.
Actually, I can be Jesse Pinkman.
I'm almost there.
I'm loading in.
I'm dropping.
I'm gonna be Scooby-Doo because he's the only other one that would be on all fours.
No, he's not.
He's not on all fours.
Where's our pony avatar?
You are a skeleton.
A spooky, scary skeleton.
Send shivers down my spine.
What else can I be?
I can be hot, though.
Here we go.
Me too.
Mine loaded at the exact same time.
When you load in, you're like, what is this?
When you load in, you're like, how is this Cloudsdale?
Oh my god.
It's clouds.
Where do we go?
Why are we so small?
What is this?
You go this way.
You go this way and you're like, that's where the city is right here.
Guys, guys, right here.
Look what I am.
Can I light the hamburger?
This is a Fortnite skin.
I'm gonna be a gamer, girl.
Guys, come over here.
We gotta get to Cloudsdale, guys.
Cloudsdale.
We gotta get to Cloudsdale, everybody.
This is cool.
I thought I was gonna fall through.
Why is Cloudsdale having such an overcast day?
We're gonna make it to Cloudsdale.
I'm stuck.
I'm not gonna make it to Cloudsdale.
I just followed you, Lime.
Oh god.
No.
We're stuck.
I'm too sexy to die here.
Buy yourself some rope with your bathwater funds.
Oh, I made it up.
See ya, Lime.
No.
What the fuck?
Guys, get there.
Guys, what if we fucked up at Cloudsdale?
I think there's a road and Doki took us through the clouds, but there's an actual road.
Why use the road when we have the clouds?
Don't worry.
The cloud is faster.
No, it's not.
Yes, it is.
Oh, did you find the road too, Snuffy?
Here we go.
Rainbow road.
How'd you get up to the road?
I just respawned.
Oh, that's better.
I saw that.
I fell through Cloudsdale.
I hear them.
Can you guys see me?
You guys are so close.
Hi, Doki.
As a host, I can TP.
Oh, wow.
Min is so far.
There's no way she'll be able to, like, overcome a nice TP.
Is that a Peter Burger?
Why don't the fries do anything?
Wait, I have an important question.
If we spawn in 50 Peter Burgers and launch them all at the same time through the link...
I'm already doing it.
There you go.
Let me launch some Peter Burgers with you.
Oh, no!
I'm respawning.
I'm taking them down.
Where's the road?
Wait,
Doki, can you TP me?
Just keep going down the road.
I can't.
Where's the road?
I actually can't TP.
I can teleport to you and be like, hey, then teleport back.
Oh, I found it.
Hey, Min.
Hey, what is...
What is Ethereal Haven?
Celestial Sanctuary, inspired by the grace and freedom of Pegasus, offers panoramic views of the sky and feelings of floating amidst the heavens with billowing clouds as backdrops.
Ethereal Haven provides...
I see the aftermath of all of it.
I'm sorry.
You were trying to have like a discussion over something and we just petered all over it by then.
No, it's just that whoever created this world has like lore.
Wait, there's a nuclear bomb, guys.
I found it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, all the progress I made trying to get to you guys.
I was basically standing on top of it when it went off.
Holy shit.
The rumbling is still happening.
I feel like I have actual hearing loss.
Oh my god.
Where are you guys?
Oh, I see you.
I'm below the road.
Just let go.
Wait,
who do I see over there?
Who's the skeleton?
Oh my god.
The thing about the nuke is that you don't even have to light it up.
You just click it.
You bring it out and it just automatically explodes.
Look at the nuke.
Oh god, it's so good.
Everything hurts.
Holy shit.
I was not supposed to know you don't detonate a nuke.
Oh god.
Look what I found, guys.
Oh, what was that?
I was called Angry Badger.
Oh, it didn't do anything.
It just exploded.
It was just an angry guy.
Just an angry little guy.
Oh!
What?
I'm trying all the other different beam ones.
They're spray mania cannons.
Yeah, I wanted the spray ones.
Ok, so nuclear bomb, you just place it, right?
Let me stay away from doing it again.
No, no, no.
This is the sphinx.
Wow, wow, wow.
It's so joyful and small and...
It's so modest.
So modest.
Oh, whoa.
What did I just press?
Oh god.
My chat's right.
We downloaded a bunch of mods and we ended up with Peter Griffin, a small kaboom thunder noise and then literally a world ending nuke.
And I wouldn't have it any other way.
Hey Mint, what you doing over there?
Whoa.
Whoa!
Is it me?
These like realistic fire effects are killing me.
This is what you've always wanted.
What?
Oh, here we go, here we go.
Light the boom, light the boom.
Ok, so if we spawn a ton of those in, we can have the world's largest firebat MP3.
Delete button, I'm getting out the delete button.
The what?
That doesn't exist, that doesn't exist.
What is the wand of wizards?
I'm off to see the wizard, the wonderful wizard of Oz.
I've enshrouded myself in a shield.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh, poop.
Poop.
Wingardium Leviosa.
Oh my god.
This was very normal.
Shrouded in poops.
I need help.
This is my protection.
Are you having...
I don't think anyone would want to go in there.
I don't think anyone would want to go in there after that.
I need to light them all up.
I helped you with that.
Oh god, I'm seeing colors.
Like, what's happening?
Why is some of the poop dropping off from the poop sphere?
Can you get out?
Can you get out of there?
Some of them lit, not all of them.
I got a little yellow.
Maybe if you put post-paint take in the middle, it'll light everything up.
Yeah, I usually drop propane if I want everything to go off.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is like the kind of thing you do to your neighbors you don't mind.
You regularly light poop on the neighbors and you're just like...
Oh, they didn't...
I think actually they went off.
It's just that they did the thing where they don't despawn.
My poop shield is...
gone.
The evil has been defeated.
We never even made it to Cloudsdale.
I know, we never even got there.
We never made it.
The nuke dropped and we never...
Oh my god, I get the 300k!
Yay, let's go!
Wait, hold on.
Yay!
Here, I'll celebrate.
I wasn't gonna show my face.
No!
Yay, yay, yay, yay!
Thank you guys!
Yeah, this is Cloudsdale.
What's the lore of Cloudsdale?
What's the lore of the weather factory?
Thank you guys!
Yay!
I mean, three!
I got stuck, hold on.
Three!
What?
What did you press?
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Oh my god, it's insane!
It's insane!
Yours did an instant detonate!
I literally put it on the floor and it just...
Mine had the bomb noise going.
The way this makes my audio sound is so funny.
My eardrums are rumbling.
Like, oh my god.
Goodbye, Cloudsdale.
You guys wanna do a new map?
You wanna do one last map?
Yay!
I set off like a wave of peters at the same time as the nuke and I thought for a second the peters had broken the fucking server.
We spawned one too many peters.
That's what I wanna do.
I wanna do the biggest peter explosion we can.
Where do we...
Okay, I'm looking at the maps.
Let's take us to the German village!
It all started!
We have to go!
We have to go.
We wanna do the German village to download custom German village map.
German village...
Is there any other mods that we want, guys?
Any specific...
My game crashed.
No way!
You're not even in the game yet and it crashed.
We downloaded German village and they're like, alright, that's enough.
You're not German enough.
Dude, I'm German for this.
Wait, there's one.
The welcome to hell mod.
What is that?
Yeah, I saw that but I think it's just more more firework stuff.
There's like random Oh wait, there's ambience mod.
What the fuck is ambience?
If you had all the patience in the world on that original map, you could do like a trail of propane tanks and fireworks that surround the entirety of the town and then go off on like a time delay by doing it with a connection thing.
Take us to Arizona.
Are we going to Arizona instead of Germany?
And then the description says the mod have added a horse that go kaboom.
Wait, what?
What is it called?
The horse go boom.
Where are you finding these?
And it says the mod have added a horse that go kaboom.
The picture is so ominous.
I kind of want to know also what happens if you spawn in like a ton of peter burgers and then everyone spawns a nuke at the same time.
Oh my god, yeah.
That's our finale.
Yeah, that's right.
Finalize the stream by crashing the shit out of the game.
Are we doing Arizona or German village, guys?
Whichever.
Pick wisely.
Germany.
Yeah, Arizona is literally a desert.
I just looked at it.
It's just a desert.
Alright, I have a lot of mods now on it.
Yes, 100 plus mods.
Germantown.
We're going to be the 125.
Oh my god, it's going so fast.
Oh my god, we're in the fucking train station.
We're in the subway.
Let us in.
Give us a car.
I'm going to attach explosive to the railway.
What the hell?
I'm going to rescue a beautiful damsel.
I think the FBI is watching us.
Why are there so much fewer servers now?
I don't know what happened.
All our friends left.
I think it's because people are going to sleep in EU.
The Europeans are heading to bed right now.
Before they go to bed, they light up a couple of fireworks.
I got my fireworks that night before I head to bed.
Nothing gets me settled to sleep than lighting up a couple of peter burgers.
My duty as an American.
Right, I guess I should be European for that.
What the fuck?
You can light up a fucking cat?
What?
Wow!
No!
How's it going, Angelina?
Don't do the cat.
Here we go.
Oh my god!
We're going to light up a cat!
Oh my god, look at them fly!
Oh my god!
What's this horror movie?
Let's get out of this subway.
Let's go see the world.
The world!
How do we get out of here?
Doki?
This is actually really scary looking.
I don't like how long this show is.
Why is it so...
Why is it so red outside?
What's happening?
What are these?
Oh my god, there's so many of them already.
Wait, I have an idea.
What if I set off a crowd of peter burgers on the back of a big one?
I want a peter burger.
Let's put that down here.
And then put a bunch of peter burgers on it.
She's off to see the moon!
Wait, the horse!
Oh my god, guess what?
This is the horse.
What is that?
Peter, the horse is here.
That's it?
The horse is underwhelming.
The horse sucks, no wonder it didn't have a good run.
Oh my god, what is this?
What is this creation?
This just makes me know that I have to...
We can ask first people to put us in the game.
If the horse can exist, somebody can light me on fire and shoot me in the head.
It's literally the workshop.
Anybody can put anything in there.
This is going to become as big as Left 4 Dead 2.
I swear.
Do we have to also put nukes?
Should we all put a nuke together?
Oh god.
Oh no, they're going off.
Oh my god, someone took a picture of the actual cat!
It's a firework!
That's Maxwell!
Who doesn't know Maxwell?
What, Doki?
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Oh god, my game is literally frozen.
My game is frozen!
I am frozen.
I think it might have...
Everything is white.
Don't go to the light!
I'm back.
What's up everybody?
What was that?
Was that the other nuke?
That was the nuke with the pita burger.
I don't think we should combine the pita burgers with the nuke anymore.
We should do it with the actual nuke.
We should do it with the regular nuke one.
With the RGB blaster.
I got a TNT, guys.
Don't make me do it.
You got what?
What's that under?
Oh my god!
It's huge!
It's so big!
Wait, what's the skeleton one?
Spooky scary skeleton.
It was nothing.
It's just literally normal fireworks.
I want to set off this bomb without it being attached to a bunch of stuff.
I'm going to set this bomb up.
I just want to see what it does.
That's the one that broke the game!
No, it was the pita burgers that did it.
That's so beautiful!
Pretty!
Oh my god!
See, when you don't decorate it with pita burgers it doesn't break the game.
Mobstone spawn, guys.
Make sure to light it up to mobstone spawn.
Spooky scary skeleton.
That thing's got a cool rhythm.
Where did you get the Minecraft stuff?
Oh, I found it.
Wait, I want to see Maxwell without the nuke going off.
Go, my Christmas rockets, go!
There he goes!
Go Maxwell, go!
There he goes.
He's getting in there, guys.
Oh, Maxwell, no!
Oh, he was so chill.
What happened?
What's going on?
Snuffy found Christmas rockets.
Christmas!
Oh no, they're just actual rocks.
Guys, I can actually build a house.
Guys, I'm going to play Minecraft now.
Yes, Minecraft!
The nuclear bomb is actually a firecracker?
Wait, you have actual Minecraft blocks.
Doki, is this a different bomb?
What is?
Look!
Wait, what the...
I found this.
This is different.
Uh-oh.
Wait a second.
Why is it close to the firecracker?
Holy shit.
I tried to blow up Doki's house with the...
Oh my god.
It looks like hell on earth.
Welcome to Germany.
Oh wow, there's a little ferris wheel.
How cute!
Where did you guys end up?
Oh no, not again.
Snuffy!
Where are you guys?
I haven't found you yet!
I can't!
I just keep bouncing in the air for the whole time.
I turned around and saw how many there were.
That was like three of them, by the way.
They look like ten.
It could be ten.
I can't believe German engineering has made these structures so strong.
How about we play hide and seek?
Someone plants a bomb and then lights it and you have to find it in time.
You have to dismantle the bomb.
I feel like I'm hearing noises weird now.
Everything sounds weird.
It's like the top exploding game.
We played that, it was fun.
Wasn't it, Snuffy?
Where did everybody go?
I'm by visual imagination.
Oh, hello!
Look, look, come here.
I found this.
Where are you guys?
You did, you did find that.
What are you going to do with it?
I'm going to add more.
Where are you guys?
They're hiding, they don't want us to spawn nukes where they are.
Why are there so many nukes?
Be careful of this area.
Wait, where is everybody?
Snuffy, you'll know.
Toki, don't do it!
I'm lowering the volume.
07 everyone.
I found Snuffy!
Oh my god!
This is the world's most resilient town.
Anyone want some hot dogs?
That one, it was all one giant explosion, but when Snuffy did it before I could see each cloud forming in the air.
I think it's because we're all bunched up together, so you put him like...
We don't need to do that again, guys.
This one's just called Kitty Poop.
Yeah, this one is the little cat.
I just blew up a Galaxy Note 7.
Wait, I wanted to see the Kitty Poop!
Now I'm stuck in a back alleyway.
I'm actually stuck in here.
Wait, no!
Ok guys, drastic times ask for drastic measures.
I'm sorry.
I need to get out of here.
Sorry, I have to get out of here.
Oh my god, it's over.
Sorry, I got out of bounds.
Sorry.
Hello?
Is somebody calling?
Hi Snuffy!
Did you see the fucking beaters?
The beaters!
The random beaters!
Oh my god, I'm out in the road.
For a minute, I thought that was the fucking Galaxy Notes because they went off at the same fucking time.
I like how the timing of Snuffy being like, is somebody calling?
Did you see the Galaxy 7?
Oh yeah, the Galaxy.
Galaxy 7, look.
Right here.
Galaxy 7, light it up.
Blow it up?
Light it up.
Mushy mushy!
How many fingers do you think we have right now?
Do you think we lost them all?
We have all sorts of radiation.
No, no!
Why are the beaters such a problem?
Holy shit.
I'm trying to fill up all my props with just the beater spawns.
I want to hear them.
I will help you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Grand finale, I will help you.
Grand finale, beaters.
More beaters.
Beaters for everyone.
Send me off, launch me.
Wait, I want to see what the pause is on Snuffy with beaters and propane tanks.
I'll go far away, I'll go far away.
I want to see what the pause is.
You can see it from over here.
As many beaters as I can withstand.
It's like a beaternado.
Yeah, this is like my, this is my little shelf.
I mean Snuffy, do you want them set up with a propane tank or do you want me to shove a nuke in the middle?
I think nukes.
I think we should just admit that we really want to put as many nukes as we possibly can and just accept that.
That's something we should do.
Oh, that was loud.
That was so loud.
It was horrible.
I'm spiraling outwards.
It looks like a hat.
Okay, I can't put anything else down.
If you guys have more nukes.
I'm done for fireworks.
Can someone who still has a slot put the nuke in there?
Oh my god, the Christmas trees.
Do we put a nuke in the middle?
Yeah, put a nuke in the middle.
Maybe remove a Christmas tree.
Nuke in the middle.
Okay, okay, okay.
You got it?
You got the nuke?
Okay.
I'm gonna put a little kitty in there.
I can have the nuke in there.
Who's doing the nuke?
Oh, I can do the nuke.
I can do the nuke.
Oh, yeah.
Where is it?
Oh, here we go.
Excuse me.
And then we'll put the Christmas tree on top.
Oh, uh, okay.
If my stream crashes, I'll miss all of you.
Before we light it up, let's put a Christmas tree at the top.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
For the holiday season.
You think it'll like...
I'll put a little bit of propane there for fun.
Hold on, let me...
I've got plenty of propane.
For the holiday season.
Put Maxwell?
Yeah, I'll put Maxwell.
I'll put one American dollar on the nuke.
Uh...
Oh, wait, before we do, let's put Christmas rock in here.
Oh, you wanted to go off singing?
That's fair.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Yay.
Oh, oh, wait, there's two nukes.
Alright, well, light it up.
Yes!
I hear them, I hear them!
I hear the Peters!
Merry Christmas, everybody!
Oh my god, it's beautiful.
Happy New Year!
I still hear the music.
How do I hear it?
I can't hear the music anymore, I got blown too far away.
Merry Christmas, everybody, and a Happy New Year!
Happy New Year!
Merry Christmas!
Yeah!
Wait,
why'd it stop playing?
I think the song ended.
Oh.
Damn, the show's over.
Go home.
It's Jingle Bells time.
You don't have to go home, but you can't stay here.
Closing time!
I got blown up so far.
Yeah, gang, yeah, woo, yeah!
Woo, gang, woo!
Merry Christmas!
Yeah!
Merry Christmas, everyone!
Merry Christmas!
Jingle Bells, Jingle Bells...
I see that Peter Burger.
Just one, just one, just one.
It's beautiful.
This was so fun!
Oh my gosh, this was a good pick for game.
Thank you!
Thank you, guys.
Good job, everybody.
Just some good old...
Merry Christmas!
It was so fun, guys!
Oh, I should be a Santa too.
Tee -tees, everybody!
Tee -tee!
Tee-tee!
It was a good game for the holiday season.
Yeah.
Very happily, we ended in German Village.
Oh, I've been a sexy girl this whole time.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna be the OG Santa.
No, nobody crashed.
We're too powerful.
Or I'll be the...
Wait, Odoki crashed on the menu.
Yeah!
That's the only crash we had.
Yeah.
Okay.
Touch the flames, touch the flames.
Wait, we can all be...
Touch the flames.
Yeah, be your most effective Santa.
Wait, I can't...
Hold on, I'm gonna switch Santa.
I can't see any...
Wait, which one?
You gotta be Red Santa.
Oh, Red Santa?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
All different Santas.
Just rub the tips together a little bit.
Just a little.
Me and my homies just touching tips.
Yeah.
This is a Santa ritual.
All of mall Santas do this.
All the Santas get...
This is how we deliver the presents.
We're lighting up the Christmas tree.
Before the Christmas Eve.
We smoking that you alone.
Thank you guys for playing.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you everyone.
I'm gonna go get something to eat.
Yeah.
GGs everybody.
Bye bye guys.
Merry Christmas.
Bye bye.
It's beautiful.
Beautiful.
Wait, are we the only ones here?
Yeah, it's just you and me.
Snuffy.
Blue Santa.
Oh, you're Santa Prime.
No, no.
You're the Santa I've always wanted to be.
I'm Proto Santa.
They found out red was a more popular color.
Now I'm gonna have to end you just like Shadow the Hedgehog.
It's all them pita burgers.
Oh, I should take another one.
What is Doki doing over there?
What?
I can't even imagine leaving this game on and not thinking what could happen.
Right?
We could do anything.
Oh god.
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
It never gets old, dude.
It doesn't, it's so good.
Bye bye!
That was so good.
That was so good, guys.
Before I leave, before we leave...
Oh my gosh, I can add all the mods we want.
Let's go to our own place.
I'm gonna get to Arizona.
Arizona.
I'm gonna subscribe.
Alright.
Alright, Arizona.
Where is it?
Where is Arizona?
Arizona.
Oh, ok.
Let's go.
Let's just, let's just...
Before 300k, let's watch our own fireworks.
Oh, I'm still Santa.
Ew, what is this piss filter?
Oh my god.
Oh, the cactus scared me.
I thought they were people.
Let's just do our own fireworks.
Just us, you know.
Just hanging out and being, you know.
Let's see, what do we want?
I'm gonna get a bunch of really cool ones, ok?
Let's just do one of each or something.
Let's just, you know.
Viper.
Viper 2.
Magic Sky.
I mean, hello!
Hello, hello!
Fried potato.
Hamburger.
Cluster.
Christmas rocket.
Wait, I already did the magic.
RGB.
Whatever this says.
World stopper.
Wait, I think I did that one too.
Amazing granny.
Amazing granny 2.
Ok, and some cakes.
Some cakes.
We'll do the fat bill because that sounds big.
Let's do...
Let's do wrap.
Oh, so tiny.
Let's do...
Low ride.
Oh, so tiny.
Let's do the messenger.
Let's do beehive.
Wait, how do I rotate these?
I don't remember.
It's fine.
Let's Nautilus.
Let's do 2024.
2024.
Dragon battery.
Oh, there is Nautilus.
Alrighty.
If I do one of these, will it do them all?
Let's do kitty.
Let's do where is Maxwell in the novelty, right?
How do I...
You can make them bigger?
No way.
You can make them big...
Oh my god.
You can make them bigger...
Oh, I think it's far...
I don't think it's bigness.
I think it's...
I think it's how far away it is from you.
What is alpha lupus?
Ok.
Alright.
Sounds like a...
Like a joke, you know?
Ok!
300k!
Maybe I should...
Oh, whoops.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
No.
Oh gosh.
Oh no.
Anyway, I meant to do this one.
Wait.
Oh gosh.
I think it was buried.
Oh, Senpai!
Thank you!
Congrats on 300k.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
I just wanna see some pretty fireworks.
Just, you know, just us guys, you know?
Thank you.
I had to turn the volume way down low.
So...
Because of, you know...
Oh wait, maybe I do this...
Oh, well, I'm not gonna do it last.
Because I already pressed it.
We'll do Peter Griffin last.
Ok!
Happy 300k!
Oh, that was literally just an explosion.
Wow!
That went so cool!
That went up there.
Wow, that went, that went, that went.
Thank
you guys!
Wait.
Wait, before, before, before, before, before...
Hold on, I'm gonna disappear for a second.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna appear to you in 2D.
I hope you guys don't mind.
I'm gonna appear to you in 2D.
Real quick.
I hope you guys don't mind.
Appear in 3...
Oh, not 3D.
2D.
One second.
So I can properly say hello.
Properly say hello.
Oh, whoops.
And properly say thank you.
2D.
Let me put on some music.
Because it's really quiet.
Oh yeah, I'll do this one.
Oh, there we go.
I was like, what the heck?
I'm not moving.
Yay!
Minto jump scare.
Yes,
thank you for 300k!
I really appreciate it!
I hope you guys like the fireworks today.
And...
Yeah!
Keep working hard to...
To get even more!
And then hopefully that leads to more opportunities.
And cool stuff for...
For...
For all of us to do.
Yeah!
Thank you!
What a stream to hit 300k on, right?
What a stream.
This is so fun!
I'm glad I picked it.
I saw that it was just a thing with multiplayer and I was like...
This looks goofy.
Oh, the mods made it so much better.
The first explosion...
The first snuffy fireworks explosion was so good.
Thank you for all the congratulations!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Happy!
I honestly...
I honestly was like...
You know...
It's kind of like...
It's kind of...
You know, I didn't think that it would be...
You know...
Maybe possible...
Like on my own.
So...
You know...
Things like this can be...
Uphill challenge for me usually.
I'm kind of...
You know, I'm kind of used to like being...
How do I say?
Like...
I don't want to say an afterthought.
You know...
But...
Okay!
I'm gonna go now.
So...
Have a good night!
Have a good day!
And I'll see you guys...
What's...
Tomorrow is Saturday, right?
I have a...
DMC!
Yeah!
Otsumito!
Bye bye!
Bye!
Thank you!